[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to our
annual special bonus videotape version
of the reason Roundtable podcast in
honor of our annual webon this the 16th
year in a row that we have asked you
dear listeners and viewers and readers
and other types of people even
commenters sometimes uh to uh consider
giving us a tax-free donation to The
Reason Foundation which publishes
everything that we do I'm Matt Welch I'm
joined from left to right here in our
Burbank Studio by Nick gpie katherin
mangu Ward and Peter sudman hello
everybody howdy hey man happy Wednesday
it's not our Burbank Studio I lied we're
in Washington DC we're in Washington DC
with a beautiful table here um yeah made
by a donor by a webathon donor next
Scott uine whose name I mispronounce
every opportunity Scott is very
difficult to figure out well we're going
to do here today is basically answer
your questions um that you submitted to
us many many questions we're not going
to probably be able to get to all of
them but we'll see what we can do with
our usual speed and Grace to sorry
answer them all um uh where you trying
to stump us and and uh and Etc but first
we're just going to give you a little I
should say but first we're going to give
you a little a bit of uh reason for the
reason season which is to say uh why uh
you should consider giving us a taxfree
donation by going to reason.com
donate um and also what you might get
when you're there why don't you lead us
off the robot with a mostess Katherine
man board so here's the thing um
basically all other Publications are bad
and I say that as somebody who reads a
lot of news all day every day and who
even has uh some Publications that she
enjoys but I think if you want a
combination of genuinely serious
investigative reporting real
factchecking and uh just like non
Insanity that we really like bring
together those three key components and
that uh it's a lonely place to be and so
you should support us in our efforts to
do reporting and journalism and Analysis
that is non
Bonkers Peter what is your reason for
the reason
season well I think the reason that
people should give money to reason is to
pay for staff and so this is this is
like a a very fundamental but I think
underrated benefit of donations is that
you need people to produce stuff and so
if you like reason's stuff whatever that
is if you if you like reason articles or
their podcasts or the events or the
whatever project and you want more of
that then there's got to be a person to
write that article or to speak into that
microphone or to manage that project and
each individual person can only do so
much we try to get them to do more like
we we extract we're like we're we're
we're great you know sort of
manipulative horrible capitalists who
just like give us more right we're like
uh all of the staffers are like sponges
and we're just squeezing them dry at the
same time sometimes you've squeezed them
dry and there's no more Pro podcasts no
more projects no more articles in them
and you need more staff and so reason
has expanded and that's why we are doing
more now than we have ever done before
but we could expand even more and we can
only do that with your donations uh
speaking of Le Zeppelin's lemon song
nicholes uh you've now had enough time
to prepare for this question what is a
good reason that people should donate
why am I
here uh I am going to uh go with the
idea that reason is your voice in public
debates over politics culture and ideas
uh we are carrying the libertarian uh
sensibility in as big a context as
anybody does um so if you believe in
libertarian ideas if you believe in free
minds and free markets support reason
we're out there all the time another
thing that we do that's related to that
is that we help create the next
generation of Libertarians uh I started
reading reason in high school it was
very foundational in the development of
my
sensibilities uh so don't blame me blame
reason magazine I guess is what I'm
saying but it's it's a a really powerful
uh transmission device to you know about
these ideas to the next people and Lord
knows uh we really need as many
Libertarians as we can find going into
2024 and Beyond uh and I will add to
those eloquent uh missives uh do it for
the funny um considering that we write
about politics and statism and other
horrible things that the government is
doing to everybody at all times uh I
think we bring a fair uh a fairly high
percentage of funny stuff Remy videos
the brothers brag this weird brain
sitting to the next next to me doing
live interviews with people um there's
the high quotient of actual laugh out
loud stuff that you can share with
people who aren't Libertarians that's
good right we like those things okay uh
enough about us uh Katherine we will get
to what you requested to me earlier but
we're going to weave it into sure the
normal things let's start going
immediately to difficult questions this
one comes from guy Smith or is it g uh
the question is I'm wagering that Nikki
Haley gets the GOP nomination o um I
might take you up on that bet ke uh if
there are no major October surprises she
would likely beat Biden so would Haley
be a net positive or negative for
libertarian ideology Katherine you're
lady you tell us yeah so I uh have gone
on the record on the reason Roundtable
saying that that sometimes Nikki Haley
says words that I don't completely hate
uh I am also more deeply and
fundamentally on the record reminding
everyone that politicians are garbage
and will disappoint you in the end Nikki
Haley is no exception I think it kind of
depends on whether the next four years
are like War having years or whether
they're domestic policy making years and
I think a Nikki Haley domestic policy
would be largely nonh horrific in most
areas and that is the nicest thing you
will ever hear me say but um I really do
not trust her to manage America's role
in the world especially given the kind
of magga pressures that would be on her
from the party um and I think that um
her performance uh you know in her role
as un Ambassador is a hint of this but
that she would be um maybe like less of
the angel of her better nature and a
little more of the Maga devil on her
shoulder as president if I had to guess
Nick I would like you to add to that and
we'll weave in as another question two
for the price one from Stephen Jackson
which goes to does reason have any
comments on the recent endorsement of
Nikki Haley by Charles KO who is a
significant supporter of the reason
foundation and might Nick do an
interview with her I would uh be happy
to talk to Nikki Haley uh anytime any
place uh behind the back stop 3:30 yeah
sure let's do that um I don't have any
uh opinion on Charles KO uh you know or
his group's endorsement of Nikki Hy uh
what I like about her is she's basically
the only candidate who's really talking
about national debt and uh deficits
which implies entitlements and things
like that I don't think that she her
reforms are the ones that I would choose
but good for her on that sudman you're a
reformer at heart I agree with what
Katherine said she would be better than
the other plausible alternatives on
domestic policy and quite worrying on
foreign policy also reason doesn't
endorse candidates why not because we
are 501c3 you know what else is true
about 501 c3s let's hear it uh donations
to them are tax deductible so we will
not be endorsing presidential candidates
which might make you want to give us
your money and if you gave us your money
you would be kind of stealing some of it
from the tax man so it's a win-win not
stealing it's totally legal it's totally
legal uh and uh uh would just add to uh
any of that that uh Nikki Haley um at
least gave one of the better speeches in
21st century American politics when she
advocated for bringing the Confederate
flag down uh from South Carolina state
house which was nice um good on her uh
yeah she seems like a competent normal
person which is actually a huge uh like
a qualification in this field and if she
wins president we're going to hate her
too so much she's still going to be a
Conservative Republican also which is
not what we are all right Doug Stewart
who is the CEO of the libertarian
Christian Institute asks an on brand
question uh I've been a listener to your
show for several years now thank you
Doug I've always appreciated the insight
and Analysis Etc I've been a Libertarian
for nearly two decades now and when I
first entered the arena it felt as
though the movement had a mostly secular
non-religious and certainly
non-Christian flavor to it despite there
being a non-trivial number of Christian
intellectual influences in the
movement's history but nowadays it seems
we find that many are coming to
libertarianism while also holding on to
their faith my question for you is this
do you think the Liberty Movement has
seen a fair share of growth by those who
aren't anti-religious and are simply
making an effort to find a way to make
their faith comport with libertarian
principles or is it just my confirmation
bias since I run an explicitly Christian
libertar Liberty organization what say
you C want you lead us off yeah I mean
this is absolutely a trend at reason as
well we have um an increasing number of
young staffers who are some flavor of
Christian and um there are two possible
explanations for this one is that yes it
reflects something real in the movement
and um if I had to make up a story about
why that is I would say it's because
Christians are uh no longer a the
dominant or even maybe a dominant force
in American society they are therefore
an position to recognize and appreciate
political philosophies that defend the
rights of minorities and hey here we are
a political philosophy that defends the
rights of minority populations Theory
number two is Stephanie Slade yes who uh
is was at one time uh lonelier um
Catholic in this case at reason and who
has uh done excellent work I think in
explicitly making the case for the
compatibility of faith and libertarian
belief and uh so maybe it's just
Stephanie SL I Nick I feel like we've
gone from atheists to lapsed Catholics
to uh whatever kind of practicing
Catholics Ste I mean yeah you're edging
that way aren't you it's been a while
been a while so oh yeah yeah I don't I
don't e cookie uh you know the one thing
I'll say to Doug is that there's
absolutely no incompatibility between
being a Christian or or being a member
of any religion I think of being
libertarian I uh am fond of the idea
that libert arianism as we kind of
understand it or Classical liberalism
really comes out of 17th century uh uh
England and the Civil War over uh the
role of forced worship uh and whatnot in
in the Church of England so I think you
see uh and David Bose I believe talks
about this in his libertarianism of
primer uh book but you know discussions
of the right of conscience to worship
God or not as you see fit is kind of
foundational to what we talk about here
so I don't think there's a contradiction
at all I got to say as a lapsed Catholic
uh with five of seven sacraments which
is pretty high up there uh it bothers me
though oh the religiosity bothers me
really yeah okay doesn't bother me
people I mean it makes it easier to shop
on Sunday but yeah yeah can I uh can I
make the controversial case that
actually the like super observant
Catholic Libertarians and the
Psychedelic Libertarians are just uh two
parts of the horseshoe waiting to come
together and that it's just all freedom
of conscience and you guys all want the
same thing and they're doing they're
eating the cracker and you're doing the
drugs but it's the same so maybe don't
be scared Peter you're a cracker who
doesn't do drugs um
you that's that's exactly how I would
describe myself having grown up in
Northern Florida and gone to school in
Kentucky at a very religious College uh
I didn't graduate from there but I was
there for five semesters one of these uh
colleges that has like a curfew every
night and you have to there's mandatory
Chapel three times a week as part of
your uh curriculum the teachers pre at
the beginning of class so I grew up uh
pretty deep in the conservative
Evangelical world uh listening to focus
on the family as well as an awful lot of
NPR actually like those were the two
kind of uh radio influences did you
listen to Christian rock oh oh yes uh
almost exclusively I could uh probably
do the whole rest of the podcast on
tooth and nail records we won't go there
I beg you not to but but what I want to
say is uh even though I am not part of
that world anymore I I really like
working at a place that can have the
lapsed Catholics and the hardcore
atheists and the people who are just
sort of like not part of this but also
the really deeply religious folks and
this is one of the the the joys and the
beauties of Reason style libertarianism
is that it allows all of these different
ideas and these different ways of living
and these different theories of what
makes a good life to coexist not just
peacefully but in a way that is friendly
and like you you get something out of
everyone gets something out of it right
it is beneficial to all that I am I am
much better off for working with Liz
wolf and Christian britchy and and
Stephanie Slade uh and I I I'm also much
better off for working with Katherine
rangi Ward who is like a like a real
like man there's absolutely nothing in
me that like that you could call a soul
like Souls don't even like souls are
it's like a it's a it's it's a you know
it's a it's a what a capital of a
country
right that's it expect the Korea the
name of a Pixar movie did you have a
born again experience I think I would
have said that I had one when I was 15
yeah and did you have a dead again
experience or did it just kind of fade
it just became less useful to me no I'm
curious because I've I've talked to a
number of born again I find religion
fascinating uh you know for all sorts of
reasons and not in a naughty way either
but you know most of the people I know
who have left Born Again Christianity it
was like a slow fade not a a reverse
Damascus Road experience I I think that
is mostly correct there there was
probably a moment when I realized oh
yeah that's not me anymore let's go to a
uh kind of mirror image of this question
from John pillow Who uh asks uh the uh
suspected Satanism is on the rise the
suspected randian influences on Brad
Bird which was mentioned in this week's
Round Table got me thinking about JD to
chili no it's not J it's a jome to
Chili's uh 1970s book it usually begins
with Ein Rand uh perhaps a better
question for him but wondering if IR
Rand is still a relevant entry drug to
the libertarian movement uh Nick why
don't you start that yeah I think so but
I think uh she has competition now uh
from Ron Paul uh and kind of all the
emanation of him as well as places like
re and magazine as an institution I um
but uh Ein Rand is still a major uh
tributary uh Katherine you're the
resident randan on at the table Yeah I
think Nick is right she's around she's
still doing her part uh she seems to be
um more like the second thing people
encounter not the first thing like the
first thing is like a meme or a Twitter
account or a podcast and then when
people want to learn more sometimes they
find rant and I think that's actually
fine too um it might among other things
prevent the um kind of um closed
ecosystem of objectivism from being
people's first encounter with this
actually very like open and like Blurry
edged cluster of ideas um and I would
add to that you know like uh criminal
justice outrage stories bring a lot of
people in um uh War um a lot of like I
just think more people become a
Libertarian by hearing am I being
detained joke or something and then like
slide their way into a book instead of
starting with the book it's stuff on the
internet that brings people in this
right that's that's the whole the whole
uh ball of stuff on the internet right
all the different things it's the
podcasts and the Tik toks and the memes
and the tweets this one comes from
Christopher Ashley uh says greetings
from Kentucky y' I have only recently
come to the libertarian liberal
persuasion he's not saying why or how
that would be interesting to know know
after spending some years as an Ardent
Republican and others as an Ardent
Democrat in terms of electoral politics
did I pick a weird time to become a
Libertarian Peter what do you have to
say about that well uh you capitalized
libertarian there capital L and it is
always a weird time to become a capital
l libertarian on the other hand free
minds and free markets reason style
lowercase L libertarianism it's always
invoke right I mean it's or it's always
it's always in it's always in style
right like it's a it's a it's or maybe
it's Style no
it's Bow's H High that's
a it's a it's a good neck tie it's a
comfortable pair of blue jeans or boots
that'll last you for the rest of your
life like there's it's always in style
it's always the right time to become
lerian yeah that's right that's exactly
right this is a piece this is a her
lowercase L libertarianism is her is a
Heritage piece that you will hand down
to the Next Generation I couldn't hate
this pitch for libertarianism more but
um yeah dude picked a really really
weird time lowercase L capital L
whatever um we are in an absolutely
Bonkers political realignment moment and
um the two major parties have aligned uh
solidly uh in a way that could be
described as just not libertarian like
that's like the shortest quickest or at
least not liberal in the classical sense
um I assume that that is part of the
reason that uh this letter writer has
evolved his political identifier
preference but um no weird really really
weird time um so in case things feel
weird now to you I guess you could take
some solace in knowing that U maybe it
won't be quite this weird for okay but
if this is a weird time then when was
the normal time like a couple years ago
when that uh like cannibalistic vampire
in Florida Satanist was running now it's
the sh is running for libertarian you're
playing a secret bingo game with
yourself as much as possible this well
Satan is my sweet master right but uh
was that did I say that I
laugh
youim uh having said this you know
Javier Malay uh was just elected
president of Argentina which is pretty
big within the US big and weird a weird
not a bad time but totally weird yeah
absolutely um I think electorally in the
unit states where you know this is kind
of a lull um compared to uh you know
maybe 2016 with Gary
Johnson uh but I suspect you know
building on with Catherine was saying
the realignment is taking place and if
you have Matt this uh you may recall the
book we co-wrote uh the Declaration of
Independence but drink at a certain
point when both parties become
anti-libertarian in every possible way
that pressure get gets pushed up to the
uh surface and I think we're on the
verge I'm sounding like Peter now of a
big bubble of uh libertarian ideas
coming up I like the optimism um yeah oh
that's not optimism it's a it is not uh
we have a lot of other related questions
about libertarianism and entry points
and and uh things to think about it but
let's mix it up with some questions
about pizza this is from Andy Jabor uh
the question is uh I grew up making
delivering and supervising at my local
dominoes during High School in college
and have a lifetime love of pizza wow I
thought there's no butt in that sension
that's funny uh when interviewing people
I often ask them to describe the perfect
pizza today I ask each of you what is
your um uh Perfect Pizza he also puts in
a u beseech me to get more active on
threads um it's pretty hard not going to
happen that's not not going to happen
the only reason I go
to threads is to repost or whatever they
call it rethread uh Andy Jabor if
there's a social media site called daddy
Wags I'm in there but other than that
I'm not gonna I'm not going to get my
Rags there uh Peter you are the pizza
expert you just wrote about this for re
Magazine from what I understand that is
correct I wrote uh like a long kind of
Deep dive into the history of pizza and
in particular frozen pizza um and so the
argument of the piece is that the very
best pizza is frozen pizza and in
particular that it is Red Baron frozen
pizza which is I believe the number two
frozen pizza brand behind Douro right we
all know it's not delivery it's Douro
Douro was a a big technological
Improvement when it debuted in the mid
1990s because it was the first rising
crust pizza that you could just put in
your oven and have at home and that
allowed them to compete with delivery
but in fact Red Baron is just better
it's less caloric it's less sort of
bready and heavy uh and it's also the
big thing about Red Baron is it's it's
pretty good and it's right there and
this is this is my perfect Pizza the
pizza that is in my hand when I want
pizza and that's the that's the great
thing about pizza historically and today
is that it comes in all all sorts of
forms and form factors right you can go
and pay $40 for just an absolutely
Exquisite expertly made you know
Heritage what Italian style like classic
it some sort of like crazy Artisan piz
it's not frozen he's like lacks the
language that's right or you can pay
$3.99 at your local grocery store
pulling something out of the freezer
case putting it in your deep freezer
downstairs forgetting that you have it
stumbling into your house at 12:30 in
the morning and thinking oh what is it
going to eat and 25 minutes later you
have Red Baron and it's pretty delicious
and that's the best pizza that you could
possibly have had at that moment Nick do
you have any Italian American objections
to what you just heard yeah and uh Matt
I want to bring it back to Little League
because I think you'll appreciate this
uh so I played for uh team in Middletown
New Jersey called the MPS the MPS and
what did it stand for it stood for
Middletown pizza oh yes and uh
Middletown Pizza had very good pizza uh
so did ninos on Route 35 near the old
path mark I will wager that any slice
that is from a non Domino's non- Pizza
Hut style chain and I've lived in a lot
of shitty parts to the country so I know
all the Mr Gades and all the pizza
buffets that are all terrible but any
slice from an independent retailer
preferably who has at least six valves
to every continent and his his or hers
first or last name uh those slices in
New Jersey are going to be superior to
just about anything anywhere else in the
planet uh I will just vote for Me and
Ed's Pizza in the LBC California get the
Canadian bacon Katherine you have pizza
thoughts or not uh my pizza thoughts are
are uh the best pizza is anchovy with
capers but I want to give a shout out to
the like maybe four slices of Hawaiian
pizza that I ate last night during our
Epic season finale of Dungeons and
Dragons I realize this makes me sound
like a contrarian monster to say both
Anchovies and Hawaiian but honestly they
are the best pizza and I will fight you
you just uh made me have to scroll up
from where I was going you really don't
have a
soul it's okay I had a friend in college
who developed a taste for pizza with
ancho so that nobody would eat them and
I was like oh that's that's pretty smart
I knew people at the restaurant I worked
at in college who smoked cloes for that
reason
yeah uh okay so this is related here
from Liam Smith uh since Katherine
brought up D and D in the Monday Round
Table how did he do that what would you
consider to be your alignment race and
class if you were playing a character as
close to your self as possible Catherine
first of all if anyone says uh anything
other than Bard at this table they have
to roll for deception because we are all
Bs um there are libertarian paladins I
think and uh I have some affinity for
the war forged which is a race of robot
creatures but um I'm currently playing a
human Rogue who is multiclass into a
Bard who uses intelligence instead of
Charisma as her as his spellcasting
modifier and uh it's a great character
and that's probably me also I'm sorry
for everything I just said also chaotic
neutral uh Peter is this a language that
you speak yeah so I'm currently playing
a rogue warlock half
orc who is who is nonbinary who is
nonbinary yeah uh but I don't think that
character reflects the truest and
deepest that character sucks if I can
just say that character is great because
that character drives all of the other
characters mad oh that's so unlike you
which is the goal of Dungeons and
Dragons is to break the game uh but no
for the I I've been playing this
character for a couple of years and the
uh for many years before that my first
character was a half elf Bard named
chinar the bararan chinar of course
being my favorite Italian bitter leor uh
and he was very much chaotic neutral uh
I uh was a dungeon master in the 70s but
I've forgotten everything except for the
funny sided dice what about uh
stratomatic I mean I mean the what we do
we only have an hour um so like I'm not
roll that die M um I will take all the
teams and divide them up I it it doesn't
matter um I'm gonna give him a twof for
here while I'm cutting off Nick um
unless you are I just wanted to say
Avatar no no but I'm a big fan of Gary
gak CJC orela has written about him for
reason but check out Gary g Who like all
Brave Pioneers who created uh more or
less Dungeons and Dragons was hounded by
the federal government because he was
too beautiful for this world and uh he
had a lot of other problems also because
a lot of people thought that he was
promoting Satanism which is I think the
reason that you brought him up maybe
maybe you know sensing a theme all right
uh I did also if I may just and this
goes out to one of my uh College friends
uh who uh when we played stratomatic
baseball and uh whenever Jerry Grody
came up he would always roll the dice
and say groy to the max there's only one
way it had a spell it had a spell power
way to do it um I was all about Ripper
Collins obviously uh let's go to
individual trained Pig for pie trainer
oh yeah the classics uh let's go to some
individual questions as if these ones
haven't been uh again from Liam Smith
Nick what dead person what dead well I
mean chopped him up into a single
sentence questions goes to the front of
the line what dead person would you most
want to have on the reason interview
podcast
Satan no Satan uh and I take this from a
book that was popular among my
Evangelical friends Satan is Alive and
Well and living on planet Earth manw so
Satan doesn't he or she I think Satan
might be non-binary I don't know for
sure but um you know I would have like
to at this point I would like to have uh
interviewed John Lennon oh yeah just cuz
he uh is a fascinating weird character
who gets more interesting the dead he is
uh I would just be about UFOs I hope is
yeah and macrobiotics uh Katherine
related question from Josh Dalton uh who
is a Libertarian or libertarian leaning
Economist or colonist that you would
love to add to the reason ranks that has
thus far been too busy or disinterested
to write for a reason that's a loaded
question I mean I absolutely have a list
like I keep a Google doc of people like
this and I who's at the top I mean I I
love me some Jane Coston and she doesn't
seem as busy these days at the New York
time Economist she a columnist or econom
she's definitely liar columnist or
Economist you said columnist or
Economist yeah and uh I think she's
awesome and I think that she would be
happy here so Jane if you're listening
which you're definitely not call me uh
let's go with Liam Smith again for
sudman a single sentence he did it he
wrote py questions Peter what one
cocktail would you most want every one
of your listeners to try just once a
really well-made my taii and the reason
is that a really well-made My Thai is a
beautiful wonderful drink that shows you
just how good a a drink that has become
trashy and uh kind of seen as oh this is
just a dumb Beach drink that maybe it's
blue God we don't don't even know what's
in this thing if you make it well with a
uh a a well-chosen blend of rums and
fresh lime juice and good orat the uh
you can make yourself or you can
purchase small hands Foods makes uh good
orot and just a little bit of extra
syrup in there and follow the like
actually follow the the recipe the
original recipe and and make this drink
the right way fresh mint crushed ice the
whole thing it's incredible and I think
this the a good my taii shows you what
the Delta is between trash versions of
cocktails that aren't thoughtful and
really thoughtful really well
constructed versions of those same
drinks you know I think the cocktail
that is best is the one that's in your
hand at 2 a.m. I don't know maybe but
sometimes that is true but the thing is
that you want to go to a place that will
put a good cocktail in your hand like
for example my basement my tie the my
taii like how alcoholic is that drink in
the original version it's like actually
not very alcoholic this is it has 2
ounces of rum and a half ounce of
quantro or grand marer
or nope there's no 151 in the original
ma Thai there is 2 ounces of rum that's
going to be in the you know 40 to 45%
alcohol by volume range and then most of
those orange Lors are 40% alcohol by
volume as well uh let's go to a frequent
correspondent Leonard
goodnight uh says hey y'all and the most
recent podcast y'all talk a lot of
y'alls Leonard yeah what's this you all
uh about moving to Florida or California
if you couldn't live where you do now DC
and New York for reference and and just
to be clear we were having a Florida
vers California theme podcast um but
let's take the coasts off the table if
you had to move to somewhere outside of
coastal elitist land where would you go
uh Alaska is also an acceptable answer
because it's Coastal but not El elitist
Coastal um who who did everyone get mad
at the most I think Katherine was the
person that people got mad at she wanted
the Bay Area the Bay Area that was the
what so where's your I'm just going to
answer the uh like the Inland Bay Area
which is Denver and uh that is the city
of my birth fun fact about me really
yeah I lived there for two whole months
before coming here and never leaving wow
but um I feel like it's got good
libertarian Vibes that have been sadly
overtaken by bad progressive government
but that we could maybe we can free
state free state our way into bringing
some of that back
Peter the realistic answer to this is
the Lexington Kentucky area where I went
to school for a number of years and
where I have a bunch of friends I love
the countryside there the cost of living
is low there's a surprisingly great food
scene and there's a lot of really good
whiskey
nick uh I don't know you don't know yeah
I don't know in Oxford Ohio yeah I I've
lived longer in Oxford Ohio than any
other part place in my life life uh Ohio
is kind of a high tax state but actually
kind of calls back to our previous
conversation the cost of living was so
much cheaper there it was you know it
was relatively uh good I don't know
myself uh Phoenix I I I have a absurd
taste for even though it's complet unab
pal Palm Springs Palm Springs is still
Coastal elitist uh enough uh somewhere
in Texas I'm not sure which one U maybe
San Antonio um is Texas on the map for
this CU so then I would probably go with
Austin Yeah Austin that sounds that
sounds about right seems like most of
our answers were cheating to be honest
except Peters Denver is fine I would
have gone there it's just a little cold
uh all right Morgan C Harper uh Hey
Round Table I've recently enlisted in
the
USMC the Marine Corps I think uh as a
combat engineer and have been struggling
to match my political beliefs
libertarianism of course to the
realities of My Life coming from a lower
income family I don't don't have many
other options to access schooling or
training without the GI bill that being
provided by the military my dad was also
a marine serving in Iraq Kuwait during
2003 he often speaks of his regret in
his role in such a corrupt war and I
think of this often he's a devout
libertarian who really formed my way of
how to look at politics and I'm looking
for input from good people like
yourselves I don't see my beliefs and
the way things are going matching at all
is joining the military mutually
exclusive to being libertarian especi
with all the pointless Wars of the past
60 years I hope this wasn't too long
please paraphrase uh Yin have a good one
and I hope this was a decent question
yes it was a very good question
Katherine why don't you lead us off so
uh I read a lot of Science Fiction and I
think one of the questions that a lot of
Science Fiction explores is or a sub a
subgenre at least explores is uh can you
be a cool badass Soldier type person and
also not be bad um and uh of course
libertarian believe in the right to
self-defense um so I do think there is
there is a role for armed Defenders of
personal Liberty uh I unfortunately do
not I personally would not be able to
square libertarian beliefs with being a
US Marine in 2023 um I think that as we
were saying earlier about a potential
Niki Haley presidency but certainly
either a trump or a Biden presidency the
likelihood that your commander-in-chief
is going to send you off to do something
profoundly anti-libertarian
is 100% um and so uh I think that that
is kind of a dealbreaker um that said I
I you know I think that there are ways
to live a Libertarian life or a life
Guided by libertarian principles within
a deeply authoritarian framework and
that that starts with freedom of
conscience so we're back to the
Catholics and the you know psychedelics
fans uh and the Mones uh I I want I want
there to be Li Li Arians in all
institutions uh and I don't even reason
even reason on occasion even on this
reminded uh that Ron Paul at his peaks
in 2008 and 2012 was pulling more
donations supposedly from Armed Force
members of the Armed Forces than any
other candidate Johnson also in 2016
pulled a whole lot I don't think there's
any uh necessary contradiction um and
then the question goes back to uh you
know the the great spe which has nothing
to do with the Marines but uh Mario
Savio the founder of the Free Speech
movement in Berkeley or not the founder
but the spokesman who talked about you
know there come times when you have to
throw your body on the machine and that
means if you're a marine uh as well as
if you're in lots of other jobs you know
sometimes you will have to say no and
become you know act on your conscience
if what you're being asked to do is
wrong but I don't think there's a
necessary U contradiction so I grew up
in the panhandle of Florida which is uh
place that has a very large military
presence and in particular the place the
area where I grew up was the home to a
lot of officers and then enlisted men um
in at who worked at egund Air Force Base
which is the research and testing
facility on the East Coast for the for
the Air Force grew up near uh bombing
range like literally went to sleep with
sorties flying over my in my house and
like could hear just the the low thump
of bombs going off around 9:00 p.m and
so this was this was the world that I
grew up in and growing up around that
and around
around a sort of career Military
Officers and enlisted men uh gave me a
great appreciation for the dysfunction
of government and bureaucracy but also a
great appreciation for the people who
serve in the military because almost to
a one they are competent they're good
folks they're people you want to have
around and have on your team and to be
doing stuff and I mean you know working
with veterans uh just you know at the
restaurant jobs that I worked at there I
mean it's a it is an institution that
does a good job of training people to be
competent in a lot of ways uh it is also
an institution that should exist in some
form like that I am not so much of an
anarchist or so much of a limited
government person that I think that we
shouldn't have a military and so I don't
think that it is necessarily
incompatible to serve and I also think
that it's like Nick said it's good to
have Libertarians in those Institutions
and it's good to have those ideas um be
be present uh at you know in all parts
of government and thank you for your
service yes damn it uh Colin blunt says
I think the 2024 election may be kind of
important given the domestic and
international unrest of the moment that
said I don't feel like voting for shaky
Joe or the orange demon um I don't know
who the Libertarians is that a uh Bruce
Springsteen song I think it's it's the
name of his new tour with Barack Obama
um I don't know who the Libertarians are
even running kind of pissed at them
after the Megan McCain tweet um voting
for The which I'm not going to explain
but God it was bad voting for The
stunningly narcissistic and corrupt
Trump or the more socially acceptably
narcissistic and corrupt Biden which may
be elder abuse are equally
unappealing uh so my question is is
there any reason to favor either of
these two miserable choices
Katherine you can always choose none of
the above and that's what I'll be
doing Shez so boring Nick you I mean you
can like he just made a wonderful case
for not voting he's true he's right that
election is important but it is not
doesn't mean you have to give your vote
to these
monsters yeah I don't think you have to
vote for either of them and the world
will get better regardless of who is
elected president it might take longer
or shorter uh but you know the fact of
the matter is that social change happens
uh not uh every one funeral at a time
but it happens sometimes because of
politics but mostly in spite of it and
uh who is president matters but what
matters more is that people are
libertarian and are pushing forward to
increase the sphere of individual
autonomy and and freedom Peter are you
gonna make this a three for three uh
well I agree with Katherine that you
don't have to vote but the way I would
say the way I would address this
question is if we end up with a Trump
versus Biden presidential race as now
seems
likely one way to think about the
question is who has the bigger downside
risk what are who has who Which
presidential candidate is going is uh
has a sort of a could cause the worst
consequences and I think POS
Libertarians possibly even the four of
us might come to different answers about
that question but think about it as who
where where are neither of these folks
is going to be good but who could be
worse and maybe vote for the other
person well you go who who do you think
that well I'm not voting for either of
them okay I mean it's isn't the short
answer to this question also like so
maybe uh we get you know January 6th on
steroids or maybe we get the Harris
presidency like that that that's the
simple way to frame this I think that's
where don't threaten democracy dies in
darkness there uh so the the literal
question is is there any reason to favor
either um and and I I just gave a reason
to favor either the the answer is yes if
if one of those things scares you more
than the other one and you live there's
a reason to disfavor one more than the
other perhaps maybe than to favor one
but that's sort of the same thing uh
Frank
olitz um that doesn't that doesn't sound
right uh this whole like letters in here
nobody pronunciation many people did say
like have had it Matt or some variant
which I appreciated uh asked to me the
mises caucus that's a r caucus the
governing one actually within the libert
Aran party seems to be the ideologically
pure wing of the libertarian party and
critical of the more pragmatic Wing is
the libertarian party unique in the
tension between ideology and pragmatism
or does this plague all political groups
is there any Group which has thus far
been immune and how was that
accomplished Nick you follow the Mis
cockus stuff uh yeah I would uh commend
people to watch Zack WIS meller and my
documentary from 2022 about the Rena
reset and we've interviewed people like
Angela McArdle and Michael Heist who's
the head of the mesus caucus I don't
believe that it is necessarily the most
principled they have principles that
they talk about and try to adhere to but
for instance uh you know the mises
caucus and the mises caucus influence
libertarian party has stopped talking
about immigration uh you know expanding
immigration as a central part of a
Libertarian political platform which
strikes me as odd um it seems to me like
it's a no-brainer to say more people
should be allowed to come here and work
legally live and work legally they don't
get welfare Etc but whatever um and I
don't but I don't think the libertarian
party is alone in having uh these kinds
of uh tensions what has happened is that
the bigger parties no longer really have
to bother to adhere to principal because
they have the votes so uh you know
certainly the Republican Party even
before Donald Trump wasn't clear what
their governing you know what their
ideal principles were uh but we know
that they were just big government
conservatives and liberals uh you know
really are not as necessarily as
hellbent on having the government
control every aspect of Our Lives as
people often attribute to them as having
covered third party people for way too
long um I I think the split isn't
between ideologically pure and pragmatic
and I agree with Nick that it's I'm not
uh uh ready to to declare the Mis caucus
swing to be the most ideologically pure
in this case um but uh it's between in
minor parties um it is between people
who are trying to get the minor parties
the most votes and even elect people and
some of the many tens of thousands of uh
of uh elected positions in this country
and those who want to use it as a
vehicle of promoting what they see is
the most purely distilled version of
that blocks ideology or belief system
and that that is an Eternal tension and
it's always exacerbated by the fact that
U marginal political parties just like
marginal ideologies and I'm just using
this as a as a visual of how many people
are at it compared to the rest of the of
the mainstream um attracts marginal
people um and you know hand straight up
uh in in that description this is not me
looking down so uh uh I think that that
is a perennial uh let's go to uh some
more uh individual ones here uh leaning
on the the frivolous ones not frivolous
but um I don't think so have you
answered a question yet direct it to I'm
going to answer one right now from Andre
Mount uh uh why laughing at a donor not
at all not at all just pronunciation why
and how did you get to the Czech
Republic oh this is good for Catherine
wait you lived in I know it's hard toak
or was it then Czechoslovakia if you
waited for the end of the question uh
more details equals better uh funny
enough no more details just not
necessarily equal better I would direct
you to a piece that Katherine
commissioned of me um a couple years ago
called the anarchic interlude um that
was a sort of a discussion of the
generation of people around my age uh
westerners who flooded into Prague at
the end of the Cold War and kind of
before the beginning of the next thing
um and most of us uh who did that did it
just because we turned 21 in 1989 that
was really the biggest thing and like oh
all this is open we did we thought it
was closed before W that looks nice
that's interesting um and that's you
know it there are potentially more High
futin ideas about that but you know uh
22-year-old's going to a place that has
the world's most delicious beer that
cost 25 cents a beer uh in a town that
is never been bombed and is as beautiful
as any place on planet Earth um it's not
a not a deep thought it ended up
becoming more interesting than all of
that for us individually did that I mean
you had libertarian uh stirrings and
things like that you know about reason
as a teenager thanks to your step father
did being in Prague make you more
libertarian and if so in what ways I
would say like more classically liberal
like I was always an anti-communist but
like uh boy nothing makes you
anti-communist like seeing communism or
seeing the communism's aftermath um and
giving you a more radical idea of like
what the state what a government should
not do and how government being involved
with things warps every single part of
human activity um uh and uh you know to
the extent sent with like it was our
common joke like every single interview
that we did cuz we had a newspaper there
would be um you know people would
explain what's happening at their place
of work or their um their line of their
place in society and they they would say
well after 40 Years of Communism comma
you know like everything's mangled uh
and it was everything was absolutely
mangled because of 40 Years of Communism
and uh and and the choices that it
voiced upon individuals that are
completely untenable the number of
people who are actually Brave and this
is probably true even of our dearest
donors and listeners who by the way sh
good reason.com
donate um to uh to uh to do that um the
people who would actually respond
bravely to a totalitarian dictatorship
who controls everything about you in
your family's life it's vanishingly
small and the amount of of uh of respect
and gratitude that we can have for those
who do fight in those circumstances
should be Limitless Katherine this
reminds me um is there different giving
levels uh at the reason uh webathon uh
and if there are can you elucidate what
they might be and and how they differ I
would love to do that Matt thank you so
much for asking me um yeah we have a
whole bunch of different tiers that you
could be in um they are cumulative so
however much you give you get all the
things from the tier below as well uh
you give us 50 bucks you get a digital
subscription and a little shout out on
Twitter or Facebook if you want 100
bucks gets you reason branded socks I am
wearing mine right now I'm not going to
show them to you you got to pay extra
for
feet yeah for what level is that's a
whole new video Chan you get a reason
branded beanie cute little hat those are
great those are fantastic you for 500
bucks you get a Yeti tumbler uh I don't
exactly understand what a tumbler is I
think it's more mug like than water
bottle like anyway you get one of those
thousand bucks gets you an invitation to
reason weekend where our donor hang out
with us and we do cool programming and
stuff a torch Bearer pin and you can
zoom with us in a kind of private off
the Record never to be released chitchat
lots of feet no feet in Fe forward we're
calling that special segment no feet uh
but you will put your best foot forward
5,000 I'm just pretending none of this
happened $5,000 get to lunch with an
editor and by an editor I mean me I'm
great at lunch you should have lunch
with me but also these Jokers if you
want um or any other editor uh on staff
you can get a you get a Fiona herrian
lunch you get a Robbie Suave lunch um
you get an Eric Bame lunch uh whatever
you want and and 10,000 bucks gets you a
ticket to reason weekend for firsttime
attendees so uh yeah it's pretty good
swag honestly this year and um one
reason the swag is the way it is is that
we kind of ran out of new t-shirt ideas
so if you have t-shirt ideas you could
just like tweet them at me or DM me or
whatever cuz that well has run dry in
the meantime so beanie Tumblr and
hanging out with us all right more
individual questions from Larry Hastings
this to Nick in a recent reason
interview video I spotted Nick using one
of those four color pens please tell me
Nick's elaborate system for color coding
his notes green for financial matters
red for thoughts on communism uh has he
considered upgrading to a 10in one with
a unicorn topper now that would be silly
yeah unicorns don't exist but bck uh but
Satan does yeah is Alive and Well she it
they are Z is alive and well um no I use
these I started buying this because I I
lose a lot of pens uh but it's mostly I
have large uh aplike hands and this you
know I think if King Kong had had access
to a b four color pen he might not have
been so angry you're the gorilla grud
liary absolutely yes I'm thinking right
now Peter read my thoughts uh special
again from Frank elitz uh Peter I like
the idea of fancy cocktails that taste
good but I'm lazy and don't want to
furnish a full bar can you suggest some
I'm going to edit that to one uh simple
cocktails using Jin as an alcohol oh
yeah you should make a bees knes it's
Jin lemon and honey syrup you have to
make the honey syrup yourself it takes
about 30 seconds you just take three
parts honey and one part water and kind
of whisk it together for about 30
seconds until it's all consistent and
then it's 2 ounces of gin and 3/4 of an
ounce of fresh lemon juice and 3/4 of an
ounce of honey syrup Shake It Up in a
Shaker with some ice then strain it out
into a coupe this whole process if you
have never done it will take you 4
minutes the second time you do it will
take you 2 minutes after you've made the
honey syrup and kept it in your fridge
it'll take less than one minute it's
very easy and it's really delicious hey
Peter are you going to make us some of
those bees KN with the honey that was
shipped to us this week by reason donor
John Maser from his hives oh yes honey
yikes uh Brian Schnack asks I'm naive
enough to believe that Iowa can beat
Michigan in the Big 10 championship and
that many people are open to free minds
and free markets if communicated in a
language that speaks to them so while
wood shipping and Chainsaw our way
toward Liberty uh generates awesome
memes I suspect it turns off most folks
triggering the New York Times and
attracting trolls while missing the mark
what prevailing libertarian metaphor or
imagery most turns off the ideal
audience what is your favorite visceral
metaphor to most effectively engage and
activate Libertarians addressable market
and then bonus points if it's sports
ball related to turn off the boss who
has a strong feeling about libertarian
metaphors Katherine me I have strong
feelings about metaphors Matt as you
know oh really uh yeah so I what would
you say your feelings are like yeah are
they like a tidal wave crashing into a
mountain so um
the metaphor that I like is uh
mandeville's Fable of the bees in which
uh the bees uh all get together and
decide to be uh good and principled bees
and then their society falls apart
because actually the thing that was
keeping be Society together was their
selfish pursuit of their self-interest
it's a a good naturalistic metaphor and
therefore avoids uh I think so often
people want to use um mechanistic
metaphors for politics for the economy
we're going to cut it or restructure it
or throttle it or give it the gas or
whatever and all those metaphors are
super disastrous because they are
fundamental misunderstanding of how
economies work economies are organic not
mechanical um I have a lot of feelings
about this but I'm going to stop talking
what I want to say is uh I think that
the letter writer is right and that um
you know a bunch of dudes walking around
with like a gun and a chainsaw maybe
make some people nervous and I get that
I am always always always is an advocate
for like being your friendly
neighborhood libertarian and just kind
of being cool about whatever people want
to do what were the bees making honey
honey it's a honey themed episode for
your cocktails or for Satan Nick you
have I'm a big fan of walking into uh
supermarkets like Whole Foods and
especially for those of us who remember
a preh Whole Foods uh kind of uh
Supermarket experience uh and it's like
desert of the 1970s yes that's right and
shopright and you Albertson's and
whatnot but uh now it's just like you go
through the produce aisle and there are
so many choices so many that are
interesting and weird and wonderful and
tasty and they smell good or they look
odd and it's fascinating and that is to
me that's what capitalism that's what
free minds and free markets brings you
is a lot of interesting stuff from all
over the world uh that is endlessly
fascina fting and you can pick and
choose among that who doesn't like a
good produce section uh ey pencil good
metaphor National divorce
bad uh Graham van curin uh writes dear
August reason knites which is more
important constitutional advocacy from
the Libertarians perspective a
emphasizing the separation of powers and
ensuring that each branch guard its
prerogatives or B emphasizing an
expansive interpretation of the Bill of
Rights including such often overlooked
gems as the ninth and 10th
amendments cther you smiling so you have
to answer this I just I just like them
all but all of those things seem
important to emphasize I don't think we
have to pick just one but um if we do I
think separation of powers is something
that people from a rhetorical point of
view I think is probably the most
important to emphasize you learn that
stuff in kindergarten right like before
your brain can understand anything about
Civics anything about government
government anything about anything maybe
this is just kids who grew up in the DC
area but I think everybody like the
first thing you learn in social studies
about the United States government is
like the separation of powers thing and
so it's deep in there it's a thing that
everyone has embedded in them that we
can like call to and resonate with and
that is a fight we might win because if
there's one thing we know is that people
in government don't trust other people
in government and that we can like
harness that this is like some
Federalist 10 stuff and it's good so
that one wow I disagree I think the Bill
of Rights uh stuff is actually more
important because libertarianism is
fundamentally a movement an an an
individualistic ideology and the Bill of
Rights is uh is all about the
protections that are afforded to the
individual and the stuff that government
cannot do to you that you have an
absolute right to you have no Duty or
responsibility to fulfill an order to
get that right you the that is simply
your right government cannot take it
from you and to me that is that is the
core of uh of of the libertarian
worldview and to we have to keep going
back to that and and pushing that yes of
course we talk about the separation of
powers and of course it's important we
don't have to choose between these
things but if we do have to choose it's
the Bill of Rights and the individual
protections all 10 of them uh that uh
that it affords to us uh I feel like uh
there needs to be an over a course
correction in realizing the separation
of power stuff like just basic should
this level of government be doing this
thing how much does that thing cost how
much do you weigh it that is just so
much out of all politics these days that
it's that it's a a grotesquery is my
feeling uh let's make a um general
question but I'll direct it at Peter for
a reasons that will become obvious Kevin
from Cedar Rapids Great Sound uh says
over the past year what cultural
recommendation either was way better
than you thought it would be or didn't
live up to the hype or what is one thing
you were looking forward to in the
coming Year from a cultural standpoint
Dune
2 it's that's what you're looking
forward to that's what I'm looking
forward that's all your answering you're
not that's my answer no disappointment
Dune two can I say my answer to the
first part is Dune one and my answer to
the second part is Dune so June 1 was
2021 so that's not the past year
whatever come on Dune I I resist your
calendar tyny there stingle in the
diaper saying I will kill you I will
kill
so good I will kill him uh Nick you live
a life of Perpetual disappointment what
was your favorite disappointment I I
don't know that I had a oh no I didn't
have any real uh super surprising
anything from scor hay and so yeah no so
that's like you know that was part of
next expectations are perfectly
calibrated Matt don't worry no not not
quite but I really enjoyed seeing Bob
Dylan uh more than I thought I would uh
to be honest and uh I also I I just we
just dropped a podcast with uh Sandra
Newman Sandra Newman the uh author of a
new novel called Julia which is a
retelling of 1984 from Julia's point of
view Winston Smith's lover who's in the
junior anti- sex league and when I heard
that the book was announced I was like
that's going to be great and it's so
much better than that like it's just I
get chill's thinking about it it's just
such a good dark gloomy and uh you know
Transcendent novel
uh my uh better than I could have ever
thought it might be would be the
baseball project which I think one uh
letter rer mentioned uh I liked it it's
fun uh Band rock band former RM guys and
other people doing songs about baseball
super dorky and wrong and I like them uh
and the thing that I'm looking forward
from a cultural but actually more
political standpoint uh next year um is
uh in in a dark morose way I'm looking
forward to the uh democratic convention
in Chicago what is wrong with you
because not okay going this you talk
about Dune one versus Dune 2 right this
is talk about staying on yeah I will uh
that's it's going to be an absolute
nightmare what an idiotic Choice uh a a
country in the I throw in a completely
useless baseball Rock tie in mattw yes
please the album by the
NZ Todd rr's original band that never
got released as such was called Fungo
bat wow see what did I tell you kther
sit up straight Leslie Peterson has a
question my real dad hi round tablers
I'm almost always a good Live and Let
Live libertarian I think I saw that
James Bond movie but there is one thing
that puts me in full authoritarian hand
me the Civil asset forfeiture stick mode
sports cars and motorcycles that are
intentionally tuned loud for maximum
horsepower I fully admit I am not being
harmed by them I'm being super duper
annoyed please help me with a rationale
for public nuisance punishment for these
horrible humans that allows me to retain
my small L libertarian card Leslie
Peterson who also adds more segment
titles please I knew you weren't a
Libertarian Leslie and that just proves
it just kidding Catherine what's up
thank you so much I appreciate this
question and now want to regulate loud
vehicles uh Leslie is being harmed
Leslie is downplaying
uh the real answer to her question which
is that she is she is absolutely uh
bearing a cost that is imposed on her by
the loud sports cars it is a negative
externality of their behavior and I feel
like if anyone can solve this it is
Robert wpol I think what we need is
micro payments for loud engines and I
don't know exactly how to do this but
like the technology is coming Matt and
maybe Elon Musk is going to give it to
us which will prove all of his critics
right that actually
uh his like libertarian intentions will
end in a dark authoritarian dystopia but
um I would feel way better about the
loud Muffler garbage outside my window
if I knew I was just getting like I
don't know a quarter every time I had to
hear it and um you should be able to do
that we got easy passes figure it out so
chat GPT right the AI of the future is
actually just going to record this and
will then extract from the car's bank
account but actually that's not going to
happen and Technology will solve this
problem because one one of the best
things about EVS from my perspective is
that they are in fact quite quiet and a
world in which most vehicles on the road
are electric vehicles uh we we might
complain about the subsidies we might
complain about a bunch of the sort of
regulatory policy environment in which
EVS are being developed right now but
EVS are so much quieter and when we get
to a world where most vehicles are EVS
that is going to be a much quieter world
that will afford US much more
concentration but won't that world also
contain people who somehow get their EVS
to make a big loud fake motor sound yes
cuz people want it yeah probably but
that big loud motor sound might be more
easily privatized in maybe you can only
hear it inside the car do you want to go
ahead and grab a smoke yeah for a while
uh I am going to uh read a question here
that's another uh conundrum to solve
we'll have Dr Nick Gillespie uh tackle
this comes from Joshua vilin uh hello
Gillespie at all we are the ATS and the
all
longtime viewer and the youngest
subscriber to the print reason magazine
here I question that at age
45 before the question I want to thank
you guys blah blah blah uh and my
question is about what the correct
solution is for the situation in Elite
institutions particularly law schools
I'll be entering law school next year
hoping to acquire a federal clerkship
even shooting for the Supreme Court oh
upon graduation which essentially
requires me to participate in a law
review every single University I'm
considering accepting from the
University of Virginia to Colombia has
an incurly one-sided skew in every
period single period research article
posted by their Flagship journals I
believe that as a Libertarian my only
choices are to silence my own views when
applying to and writing for a law review
or to be honest and lose all chance of
being accepted I'm conflicted between my
belief that the government shouldn't get
involved in University processes
especially student L ones and the
impossibility of this exclusion of
libertarian and right-wing ideas ever
changing on its own what is your
proposed solution to this conundrum Dr
gpie uh well first to maybe uh maybe the
problem is as bad as you think since
there's a lot of uh you know supposedly
un popular views on the Supreme Court as
we sit so you know my sense of things
and I flirted with Academia it's like
you can never you should never hide what
you truly believe um you know in your AC
ademic work or or in your journalism
like if you're not if you don't believe
what you're writing in your work is
going to suck anyway but you just got to
go and try and uh beat the institution
by being more brilliant than other
people if your view is heterodox or in
the minority I'm reading uh Jennifer
Burns new biography of Milton Freedman
the last conservative and uh which is a
fascinating and and Brilliant book about
a fascinating and Brilliant person and
his and all of the people around him how
did he succeed his his views were never
popular he persisted and he won over
argument so I think that's you know
there's no way but uh being who you are
and then being better than the people
around you you can also organize and
this is what the Federalist Society has
done is make a a kind of institutional
space within the world of of law for
people who are not liberals who are not
progressives who are not on the left and
organizing other people who view who
have the same views right and I don't
mean organize in a sort of like we're
going to get legal protections I mean
create institutions create forums create
places for people to feel safe and and
view that as part of your mission in uh
you know in whatever institution or
academic field that you go into I also
did not do this because I was too dumb
but um you can avoid using labels I
think that is permissible subterfuge so
say what you believe but don't go out of
way to say I'm a Libertarian like that's
fine because for the vast majority of
people it's the label that they're going
to be turned off by and if you just make
a compelling case for any individual
thing at any individual time I think
that gives you a big advantage and that
you know as Nick said even can sort of
um my former boss John Tierney who came
up uh in the New York Times was just a
Libertarian but he just usually didn't
use that word and so people were like oh
my God he has so many interesting and
unusual ideas where does this guy keep
coming up with these and it was it was
actually playing the homogeneity of the
institution to your advantage it
wouldn't even occur to them to ask are
you not what we all are um so that might
be an option as well as a Libertarian I
think that's a very good idea I think
there's always Place uh there's always
going to be some tiny little appetite in
even the most academic context for uh
someone who is a good contrarian of what
the most popular thing I remember I
wasn't a good contrarian I wasn't a good
student but when I was in film school at
UC Santa Barbara um you know I was
always the guy who would write the the
only moral character in rear window is
the guy who killed his wife that kind of
crap and they ate it up they loved it
yeah they loved it and I Raymond B
Raymond bur yeah yeah ironsight
ironsight um I'm gonna I'm gonna make an
executive decision right now and say
this is our last question and let's
we've been going for more than an hour
we can um you know have our final
closing statements if we so choose and
and and such like but this is a good
thing for us to chew on perhaps is it
another Ramen bur question uh every
question that is not explicitly about sa
is about Raymond Bird Larry
Samuels why that's not a hard word
Samuels Samuels that's how we do it shut
it uh big thanks to you all at the
reason round for podcast here's my
question um the
250th anniversary of the United States
is not that far off
2026 um what what sort of celebratory
events would you like to see as part of
this I suppose the term events can
include such things as passing or even
removing laws uh Nick and I are old
enough to remember how glorious 1976 was
yeah yeah the bicentennial I I would
like to answer for Nick can I guess what
Nick's be what I'm GNA say it's it's a
reboot of the musical 1776 oh that would
be good and uh the trick all Latino the
tricky part is it has to be rebooted not
not in Hamilton style it has to be a
non-woke reboot of 1776 that somehow
becomes mainstream that is my one and
only wish and I believe it is Nick's one
and only wish I that is great I I would
go with that I was going to say I what I
want the reboot is of the tall ships
yeah uh and I growing up on the uh you
know on near the beach in New Jersey
where a lot of the tall ships came uh it
was so stupid and then the funniest
thing and Matt you'll recall this it was
a simpler worse America but uh where
polish jokes were popular uh and uh the
Polish ships showed up like a year
later which was like okay you're doing
it to yourself now you know don't blame
us we're just you know what is uh what
is Katherine's Katherine answer I I just
got so excited about the 1776 R I don't
have anything else um an all woman
reboot of 1776 right no again again I we
have to resist the the call to go
Hamilton Style America does not need you
have the husband Dolly Madison version
Oh the first gentleman first gentleman
Ro this is just all writing itself it is
but they have to keep the songs exactly
the same including cool cool
conservative men what is it cool and
then also the song where they choose the
national bird with the turkey the turkey
round um I don't know I'm just happy for
America to have a nice birthday honestly
we weren't sure we were going to make it
I think should be a a special issue of
re magazine oh yeah that's 250 pages
long how about that yeah how how dare
you yeah you know what would be a a fun
project to think of not for reason
necessarily but what you know what is
the definition of what it means to be
American why wouldn't that be for reason
well I mean it could be I'm just saying
for for you I know you hate when I bring
up the idea of we need better
conversations or discussions but the
national conversation I'm thinking of
for our Florida issue which is really
fantastic I interviewed Jeb Bush and we
ended up talking about okay you know
what's the identity for America you know
it's clear that we're no long we no
longer think of ourselves primarily as a
nation of immigrants even though we have
more foreign born people you know than
we've had in a hundred years uh we don't
really think of ourselves in terms of
like 19th century identities Etc and
like we we need a good answer to that
like what's something that's loose
enough that binds us all together but is
also kind of permeable enough so that it
it you know it it allows for a lot of
individualization I think what we need
Peter and you'll back me up on this is
um uh a a a movie or a series of movies
um in which uh various uh key uh
founding uh fathers and figures um just
show up in the present and have to make
do and and try to like do their politics
in the current situation you want a
George Mason Time Heist film I want to
say John Calhoun Dropped In Harlem yeah
mie so short yeah yeah hi he do be
expanish so that'll be a problem I think
we had that movie already and it was
called Bill and Ted's Bogus Journey
that's true that's true and also on the
other hand maybe that's what I want for
America in in two years is just for
everybody two and a half two two years
in a month is for everyone to watch Bill
and Ted's Bogus Journey and just chill
out for a little while just setting your
sights lower by the second Peter sudman
no uh uh everybody should try a little
bit of James E pepper 1776 Rye it's 100
Proof it's pretty affordable it's tasty
and it's thematically appropriate that's
what I want for America I just want uh
us to reclaim uh or go back to 1976 uh
schlocky patriotic fashion so just like
red white and blue dolphin shorts and
like uh like tube socks and roller
skates and stuff myad d uh who was a an
English grad student in the 1970s uh
before he was my father had a pair of
custommade American flag bell
bottoms I think my dad had those too um
SE sest Centennial is the word for the
250th anniversary a little bit too much
which I will be using
aggressively that
year uh all right well thank you all for
your questions sorry we didn't get to
all of them but you that would take 10
hours um and even we don't like each
other's company for 10 consecutive hours
at least well we're videotaping um
Katherine do you want to give a a
closing statement do you want to tell us
what we've learned
today the real libertarianism is the
friends we made along the way not wrong
it's not wrong actually uh yeah I'll go
with that um the real libertarianism is
the friends we made along the way uh as
Peter said at the beginning um what we
do here at reason is mostly people but
but also uh the people on staff but also
um y'alls out there in TV Land and
podcast land and uh reading your
magazine on the toilet land and whoever
else you are um these questions are
always great like I always have a little
warm fuzzy moment where like I am
delighted by the weird and deep and like
very personally important questions that
people send in for this thing um and
this is these are the questions we try
to keep in mind when we do our
journalism every day um um I am I am
hoping that we will carry some of the
spirit of this into the next year and I
hoping that we can do that with your
support beautiful Nick anything to add
Peter anything to add you have to sing
in harmony is what I'm yeah I'm out no I
just uh thank you for everybody who uh
reads our stuff and shares it and people
who support it it's great and we can't
do it without you so thank you very much
thanks for reading thanks for listening
thanks for supporting us uh and yes and
thanks for getting to the end of this uh
special bonus
videotaped uh uh edition of the uh is it
called videotaped say no absolutely not
nor is a zoom a call but you're
encourageable we're putting it on laser
dis uh sounds great uh thanks and please
tune in on our normal Mondays for our
normal Monday behaviors and go to
reason.com
donate do it today you'll be glad you
did
[Music]
goodbye